that it is a Bittersweet night for you
all a very classy move to put Lance at
the front of the Marquee and we have the
blue ribbons in honor of him just just
your thoughts maybe even just your
feelings about him your friend and
working with
yeah
um
Lance is a
was is a very
beautiful person and special artist and
uh
his grace and dignity
his Shining Light of character
was just something really special and uh
really grateful I had the chance to know
him and work with him over almost 10
years
yeah
it's beautiful it really is and I know
you're you're all of your hearts are
with him and his family I want to ask
you two because we we know that you had
kind of um a stunt wish list for chapter
three did you have one for chapter four
and what was on that wish list
oh
um I actually didn't have any wish lists
for chapter four I had more story wish
lists
for Chad stachelski had a very long wish
list
and and it looked really good and so I
was just trying to make Chad happy
yeah you want to do whatever he said so
so the question that I think a lot of
people have because you know you're
still the baddest assassin out there but
you're doing it with nine fingers now
so how did we do this in this did you
have like a green screen wrapped around
your how did you pull that off and did
the fighting style chain
um yeah I had a what do I call it an
apparatus not quite a nap I had a
covering for my finger okay yeah so I
had to pay attention to it at certain
times and but uh otherwise it was not an
impairment so the fighting style didn't
change much it's just the look yeah yeah
it didn't it didn't really
they would fill it in they would take it
away so I could still do the grabbing
the weapon stuff wasn't really affected
you know
a little bit more for every film do you
have more in you for the franchise
you know when you love something you
always have a little bit more